Speaker 1: This is kind of interesting.
We have a bunch of primaries today.
There's primaries today in Pennsylvania. There's
also primaries today in North Carolina. In North
Carolina, one of the people that is up
for election for reelection is radical,
Trumpist Republican Congressman Madison Cawthorn.
Now, because of Madison Cawthorn, habitual
lawbreaking and also I guess we would call
them off color comments about Washington, D.C.,
about orgies and cocaine. So you might remember
he's now been caught two or three times trying to
bring guns through TSA security. He's had a bunch
of police interactions involving speeding. And I
don't remember if it went over to reckless driving
or not. The Republican Party leadership seems
to not be thrilled with Madison Cawthorn, and
it's believed, although it has not been proven,
that it is the Republican Party that is behind
some of these distasteful, I guess we would call
them or videos, the compromising videos. I don't
even know what term to use racy videos of Madison
Cawthorn that have been released, the idea being
that the Republican Party establishment is kind of
sick of Cawthorn and they want him out. Well, he's
in his primary fight and that primary is today.
And even though he is still winning, Donald Trump
now seems to have come out of the woodwork posting
untruth, social truth, censure. Yeah, he calls
it. Essential, I call it truth social. Donald
Trump sort of trying to help Madison Cawthorn in
defending him, posting, quote, at 18 years of age,
Madison Cawthorn, the now 26 year old congressman
from the great state of North Carolina, went
through a life changing event, the likes of which,
fortunately, few people will ever have to endure.
In just seconds, he lost the use of the lower
half of his body. A traumatic experience, to
say the least. That that's true. He was in a car
accident. Terrible. When Madison was first elected
to Congress, he did a great job recently. He made
some foolish mistakes, which I don't believe he'll
make again. Let's give Madison a second chance.
So there is a bunch of funny things about this.
The first layer of this is that look at how long
Donald Trump waited to make this endorsement of
Madison Cawthorn. Why did Trump wait so long? He
wanted to make sure he wasn't endorsing a loser,
even though Madison Cawthorn has lost
significant support, significant support
for the, uh, from the Republican
Party and within his primary,
it is now pretty clear that he's going to win
the primary. I would be shocked if the polling
is wrong. He's still he's ahead by less, but he's
still ahead. I would be shocked if he lost. Trump
is coming out with this the day before the primary
because Trump is very concerned with his record
and we are now going to see what the ultimate
results are. But Trump, if Trump doesn't
particularly care about Cawthorn, other than sure,
Cawthorn is a supporter of Trump. Trump just wants
to tack on wins under his supposedly great
endorsement record, which is actually sort of
mediocre. That's number one. Number two, this is
another reminder that the norms of the Republican
Party Trump genuinely doesn't care about them.
And we sort of knew that Madison Cawthorn talking
about orgies and cocaine and all these different
things. Trump genuinely doesn't care about that.
And it reminds us of what early on in the 2016
primary with the Republican Party created a rift
between Trump and other Republicans. Turns out
that Trump will just support anybody that supports
him, assuming it won't be hurtful to Trump or
damaging to Trump in some way. And that's exactly
what we are seeing here. So we're going to follow
all of these results tonight in Pennsylvania will
be streaming results live. North Carolina will
be streaming results live. I hope you'll join
me will be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
And we will also have more on these stories on
all of our platforms, including Instagram,
where you can find us at David Pakman Show